[Music]
he likes to show off his hardware I'm
not he's got it like in his window some
people put like Christmas lights or
menorah Ben lines up his heart oh yeah
see that's probably about for you right
there Casey Affleck got a little digging
after he won his Golden Globe
those two really are close been to that
fist pump when Casey's name was
announced in then I'm the party it was
boys night for the Boston bros Casey
arrived at the Amazon afterparty
clutching his new hardware and hung with
Ben and Matt Damon been nailing the
finger point place meantime over at the
HBO party it was ladies night Reese
Witherspoon and Nicole Kidman's big
little lies and muse on the network next
month I love that you're presenting
together I love that your girlfriend's
in real life and see in 10 years our
husbands are over there but as for those
rumors Nicole wants more kids with hubby
Keith Urban winner Sarah Paulson hinted
drinks were in her future while on the
red carpet she hit up the Fox bash with
the People vs OJ Simpson co-stars
including Cuba Gooding jr. he was the
life of the party dancing pouring drinks
before turning a bucket of KFC into a
hat over at the nbc/universal party
sisters Kendall and Kylie Jenner opted
for top knots and sky high slits
[Music]